françois noël buffet en retiendra des
mots forts incompréhensible indulgence
de la hiérarchie chaîne
d'irresponsabilité qu'est-ce qui lé plus
grave dans ce rapport au delà des
personnes elles-mêmes
c'est tout le dispositif de contrôle
fonctionnement de des collaborateurs de
l'elysée en l'occurrence pourquoi
lorsqu'on termine sa fonction on ne rend
pas immédiatement ses passeports et on
se rend compte trois mois plus tard
qu'ils sont encore dans la nature
pourquoi un téléphone crypté il trace
sécurisé on le retrouve pas pendant un
mois on sait pas où il est mais on
s'interroge pas pourquoi lorsque l'on
recrute un collaborateur
on ne vérifie pas s'il n'y a pas
d'épreuve de conflit d'intérêts at il
des activités autres que celles pour
lequel il prétend travailler si on avait
fait ces déclarations à l'autorité sur
la transparence de la vie publique
eh bien on se sera aperçu de ce risque
là avec monsieur b à la circonstance
pourquoi lorsque l'on demande trois fois
un port d'armes qu'ils aient refusé
eh bien il faut une insistance
élyséennes pour obtenir ce port d'armes
alors même qu'on n'y a pas droit
pourquoi dans une fiche de poste on vous
dit que vous avez une mission de
sécurité alors même que la protection du
président de la république a bénéficient
d'un service spécialisé et qui s'occupe
de lui dénoncé lé métier c'est tout ce
système là qui est tout à fait étonnant
pourquoi lorsque monsieur b n'a par
exemple voyagent plus de 23 fois entre
le 1er août du mois de décembre
on sait qu'il n'a pas rendu ses
passeports quai d'orsay vous dis ben
ouais on peut pas récupérer le passeport
pourquoi on avertit par la paf police de
l'air et des frontières parle on en dire
attention si c'est tout ça qui font
c'est incroyable vous avez des mots très
durs on vous dit l'exécutif a été en
dessous tout dans cette affaire
oui je le pense sincèrement nous sommes
au plus haut niveau de l'état dans un
lieu qui doit être exemplaire
al parce que c'est lui qui donne la
confiance à c'est lui qui inspire le
respect lorsque l'elysée dit quelque
chose c'est parole de vérité et ça doit
être parole de vérité et donc on attend
que dans son organisation
on s est excellent de vertu qui est
celle de
là les qualités supérieures de la vérité
de la sincérité des choses soient
claires jusqu'où ira cette affaire
philippe bas le président la commission
des lois a clairement demandé hier au
procureur d'ouvrir une enquête
il y as par jour pour vous il faut
ouvrir une enquête il faut de nouvelles
poursuites judiciaires en toute
hypothèse il faut que l'on saisisse le
procureur public après le prochain la
plus tu décideras puisqu'il concerne
l'opportunité des poursuites
mais l'infraction constituée par le fait
de mentir devant la commission des lois
devant la commission denquête pardon
alors qu'on était sous serment et qu'on
a juré de dire la vérité constitue en
elle-même une infraction
donc je n'imagine pas que le programme 8
ne poursuivent pas sur la base d'une
infraction alors l'autre aspect bien sûr
c'est l'aspect politique on va en parler
est une sorte de nouveau bras de fer qui
né entre le sénat et l'exécutif et
l'elysée emmanuel macron la réplique
hier à ce rapport de l'exécutif n'a pas
tardé benjamin griveaux le porte parole
du gouvernement a parlé de contrevérités
la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet juge elle que le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
n'auraient pas été respectées par les
sénateurs par la commission denquête
hier soir seule concession
l'elysée a parlé d'un manque de
clairvoyance et donc on voit un nouveau
bras de fer qui s'ouvre entre l'exécutif
et le sénat c'est un sujet de fabien
becker en toile de fond de la sphère
benalla l'exécutif a engagé un bras de
fer avec le sénat pour l'elysée les
travaux de la commission denquête ont
une visée politique est une cible
emmanuel macron il va la responsable il
est devant vous recherchez
[Applaudissements]
personne n'est dupe de ce qui se passe
de ce qui s'est passé cet été de
l'instrumentalisation de ce qui est tout
de même une dérive au départ personnel
pour la majorité présidentielle
l'opposition et en particulier la droite
sénatoriale serait donc engagée dans une
chasse aux sorcières pour affaiblir le
président de la république et
porteraient surtout atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs
je pense que ça pose en précédent c'est
pas à l'assemblée ni au sénat de rendre
la justice sur quelques affaires que ce
soit sinon ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire qu'on va créer des commissions
d'enquêté systématiquement pour
doublonner des enquêtes en cours
les sénateurs n'enquête pas sur les
faits reprochés à alexandre benalla le
1er mai dernier
mais sur une chaîne de
dysfonctionnements au sein de l'appareil
d'état
il affirme donc jouer le rôle de
surveillance de l'exécutif qui incombent
au parlement nous n'avons pas attachés à
ces tentatives de créer la polémique ou
de pression la moindre importance
senna est libre et indépendant il a fait
son travail avec sérénité avec humilité
aussi et le porte parole du gouvernement
n'attend pas d'avoir eu le rapport entre
les mains pour riposter
le lycée aura l'occasion d'apporter des
réponses factuelles sur manifestement
beaucoup de contre vérités qui se trouve
présente dans le rapport il appartiendra
désormais à la justice de donner une
suite aux éléments avancés par la
commission denquête françois noël buffet
à l'instant sur ce plateau marc fesneau
le ministre des relations avec le
parlement dit que la commission denquête
dont vous faites partie à des visées
politiques elle ce qu'ils se trompent
bien sûr qu'ils se trompent et puis
chacun sait que c'est la défense de ceux
qui n'ont pas grand chose à dire sur le
fond je note par ailleurs que personne
dément ce qui a été écrit on conteste le
rôle de la commission denquête le sénat
est dans son rôle constitutionnel de
contrôle de l'exécutif
naturellement que nous avons veillé à
respecter les obligations qui sont les
nôtres ne pas interférer dans une
question judiciaire via le voir dans le
sujet aurore bergé est la porte parole
de la république en marche
tout cela crée un précédent dangereux
est ce qu'elle se trompe
le sénat n'est pas dans une posture
politique ans est bien sûr qu'elle se
trompe
évidemment qu'elle se trompe lisant le
rapport que chacun se l'approprient de
tête sur internet et vous verrez que les
choses sont objectives et claire je
comprends qu'ils gênent l'exécutif ce
rapport évidemment qu'il le gène mais il
n'empêche que c'est la liberté et
l'indépendance du sénat d'exercer ce
pouvoir de contrôle quand bien même
l'exécutif aurait contesté le rôle de
cette commission denquête alors il
fallait que les ministres ne viennent
pas à aux auditions à laquelle ils
avaient été invités
il fallait dire nous n'y allons pas
parce que nous estimons que or ils sont
venus et ils ont dit des choses
d'ailleurs c'est tout de même
extrêmement rare que le sénat a demandé
pensez que le bureau du sénat demande de
saisir la justice devant des poursuites
pour parjure oui c'est vrai extrêmement
accera parce que c'est en même temps
exceptionnel c'est à dire peu de monde
s'autorise à mentir devant une
commission denquête alors qu'ils sont
prêtés serment de dire la vérité quand
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux on
l'a entendu également
elle juge que le prélat d'hier que le
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
n'aurait pas été respecté c'est la garde
des sceaux tout de même oui l'adieu au
mois de septembre
on a vu le résultat de dia égal mais
elle l'a redit à rueil la du mois de
septembre le redis aujourd'hui
mais une fois de plus j'aurais dit si
vraiment la garde des sceaux était
convaincu de son propos elle aurait
dissuadé ses collègues de venir devant
la commission les choses auraient été
clair france à vahirua l'instant vient
de déclarer que on voit bien qu'il ya
une certaine d'élection du sénat de la
commission d' enquête du sénat dans
cette affaire ce que dit françois bayrou
à l'instant
delic au phoque ce que ça veut dire y'a
pas de plaisir particulier il ya juste
le fait je rappelle quand même depuis le
début de mettre à jour des comportements
des attitudes qui met en cause la
sécurité du président de la république y
roule pour emmanuel macron françois
bayrou voit c'est pas nouveau ça et le
soutien le soutien clairement pour venir
sur vos conclusions françois noël buffet
dans ce rapport vous ne demandez pas des
poursuites uniquement contre alexandre
bédat là vous mettez également en course
et c'était d'ailleurs une des surprises
il ya dans ce rapport vous mettez en
cause trois des plus hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée patrick
strzoda qu'est le directeur de cabinet
des manuels macro alexis colère qu'elle
secrétaire général de l'elysée ainsi que
le général lionel lavergne le chef du
groupe de sécurité de la présidence
c'est tout là ma chronique est en cause
le degré de il ya un degré en réalité
entre ce que l'on demande à l'égard de
monsieur bénalia de monsieur crasse
parce que le parjure est établi à
l'égard des trois autres c'est parce que
la commission a constaté qu'il y avait
une distorsion entre les déclarations
qui ont été faites devant devant telle
est la réalité des faits et notamment
sur le rôle de monsieur benalla au sein
de l'elysée dans sa mission de sécurité
et ce que dit la commission elle
interroge le procureur de la république
s'il se saisit de savoir si dans ce cas
là le fait de ne pas dire les choses
constitue en soit le fait d'un mensonge
par omission
donc le degré d'affirmation de la
commission est moindre tout même mais le
constat est là donc on ne pouvait pas en
rester simplement là pour terminer sur
ce rapport vos préconisations quelles
sont elles
c'est une 13 propositions qui sont
faites par la commission avec une
volonté de transparence dans le
recrutement des personnels de façon que
les choses soient parfaitement claires
au même titre que pour les
fonctionnaires il faut que ce soient
parfaitement claires pour les cabinets
qu'on s'attache de savoir si les
conflits d'intérêts possibles si les
compétences retenu pour occuper le poste
sont bien celles de la personne qui est
candidate que l'on contrôle également vu
le retour des passeports ou le fait de
rendre
les passeports ou le téléphone que vous
avez à votre disposition en cas de
fonction que les choses soient
clairement fait au moment du départ du
collaborateur est évidemment que la
preuve l'état notamment le quai d'orsay
miss à l'intérieur c'est affaire de
passeport se mettent d'accord sur un
plan technique parce qu'on a constaté
qu'ils avaient aussi ça c'est ce type de
mesures dont nous avons besoin